okay it's really important to understand
how very coherent and well executed
narratives have been crafted by Donald
Trump and the people around him about
the Moller report I know at the end of
last segment I mentioned that they
really set this entire thing up very
very astutely and I wanted to get into
that a little bit more now I'm praising
Donald Trump and his team here because
this is this is actually evil genius I'm
not being sarcastic
I'm not being sardonic I don't like it I
don't think it's good for the country I
don't think it's good for people who
care about truth and reality but they
are doing a textbook job of building a
narrative that is sticking with his
supporters and even with some centrists
and leftists all along as we waited for
the Muller report Trump insisted there
was no collusion his attorneys like Rudy
Giuliani went on TV and radio and they
sort of set expectations that this could
be bad they don't think Trump truly did
anything wrong but the report could be
really damaging to Trump even though
I've been telling you for more than a
year the chances of Muller saying Trump
personally colluded with Russia are to
quote myself from a year ago almost zero
so then when the report comes out we
knew that they would be able to say this
is it this is everything what a waste of
time
this entire investigation has been in
the midst of all this as they're waiting
for the report Trump seeks out and finds
the perfect Attorney General to put into
manage the report William Barr who
doesn't even believe at a fundamental
level that a president can be charged
with obstruction I mean it's like
perfect they're doing everything right
the report comes out molars summary of
the report is three to four hundred
pages as we learned over the weekend
that's delivered to William Barr and
William Barr puts out a letter in four
pages just perfectly fomenting the
narrative for Trump and his cronies they
cherry pick pieces including mostly
things that are advantageous to Trump
excluding the vast majority of the
report using legalese that sometimes
confusing and sometimes sometimes
contradictory as I pointed out last week
and that bogus letter in the absence of
the actual report from Robert Muller
which now they're going out of the
to hide from being published in full
becomes the basis for Donald Trump and
his kids and Fox News and Rush Limbaugh
and right-wing media to do the victory
lap that they've been doing they do the
exoneration World Tour they're printing
t-shirts that say no collusion Trump's
calling in to TV shows about it and
remember all of this is based on William
bars bogus letter which I said a year
ago was never going to say Trump
personally colluded and we have now
learned
according to William Barr himself was
not even really meant to be a
comprehensive summary of the
investigation that gets us to this
weekend Donald Trump on his victory tour
went to Grand Rapids Michigan and within
90 seconds of starting his speech lies
and says that the report found no
obstruction now the one one of the very
few quotes from molars actual summary
that William bar included in his letter
was that Robert Miller cannot exonerate
Donald Trump from obstruction and yet
here's Donald Trump in the first minute
and a half of his victory speech at
Grand Rapids Michigan the special
counsel completed its report and found
no collusion and no obstruction that is
a lie that's a lie I mean there's no
other way to say it we don't know what
the underlying evidence is but even bars
report admits that Trump was not
exonerated from collusion Moeller was
not able to exonerate Donald Trump from
collusion but it doesn't matter they've
played this perfectly and as I said last
Monday unless something changes Donald
Trump is quickly accelerating towards
re-election in 2020 and I mean you know
people joke around Pat sometimes people
call in they say David can you name
things that you agree with Donald Trump
with and I have like a couple minor
things that I think I happen to agree
with them on this is not that I agree
with him but I can't say anything other
than they've they've played this really
really well
yeah really well especially putting
Attorney General William Barr in there
they had the time to do it because the
investigation took a long time
also try
lies all the time so it's not like the
meteor is going to report on this
specific lie furthermore Trump
supporters aren't going to fact-check
Trump they're not going to read the
four-page summary or letter for
themselves so he's able to get away with
it and then ultimately obstruction of
justice is supposed to be something
taken up by Congress not by the Attorney
General so if we get the full report and
Democrats decide they do want to take up
Trump on his obstruction of justice try
to impeach him then it's going to be
seen by many as the witch-hunt that
Trump called it in the first place like
this has already been litigated the DOJ
has already exonerated Trump for
obstruction of justice why is Congress
looking into it so they have definitely
played it perfectly no question about it
and okay I mean now what I mean the
Moller grand jury actually is continuing
a lot of people don't don't know that
there may well be more indictments the
Trump financial fraud continue cases
continue the fraud also continues I
would argue trying to get Trump's taxes
continues Southern District of New York
continues but I say forget about it I
mean let let them do their work
something might come from it but none of
those things are 20/20 strategies I'm
going to talk about that in the next
segment with David Farris Democrats need
to put together a strong platform and a
winning candidate and so far I have not
I'm not feeling any confidence that that
is what Democrats are doing for the time
being so let it all continue to happen
but you've got to start dealing
seriously with how are you going to
defeat Trump in 2020 because that's the
most direct path to actually removing
him from the White House as I've been
saying now for a long time one of
today's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to
create multiple virtual cards delete
cards freeze and unfreeze cards you can
put a limit on a card so a company won't
be able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below